are you doing this you're
wasting your life away you're not only
insulting everybody around you and your
talent and your and your stage presence
and everything you have going for you
but it's just the waist we were like
this we were like this and then and then
at some point you went off like this and
I stick and I stayed the course and I've
stayed the course for seven years
and that's why i love
at one point I really admired you I
really I really thought that you had
potential out here and you're funny any
and you charismatic and when I met you
you were a different person and I look
at you you got a shirt that says big
mistake on it you think you're giving
back to the world are you giving back to
the world by smoking pot yes yeah the
world is in me